we got a sneak peek at Adam Levine's a  bald head over the summer on Instagram  but we got to see the look make its TV  debut Monday night on The Voice of  course Blake Shelton had plenty of jokes  I have the best team right now you're  gonna change that could change it's  frustrating in and I mean it's like now  but you've been pulling your hair out  bout it happen that's funny as a hair  joke I'd like to go on record and say  that I was genuinely trying to give you  my most honest genuine and heartfelt  advice very honorable man that Gandhi  down there this is an epic battle  there are you gonna go a superwoman or  Lex Luthor down there  Adam defended his look on Twitter  writing excuse me  Lex Luthor was bald I haven't shaved my  head meaning I shaved my choice big  difference okay okay but for the record  the shaved head did not last long  Adams already growing out his hair